[Applause]
behind the doors
in an old corrugated hangar we found
medics and mechanics
and a mountain pilot saying a little
prayer
for their mission is testing and their
responsibilities great
millions of people are counting on them
this is a mobile clinic with a doctor
and a nurse
who provide health care in the kingdom
of lesotho
a mountainous territory which sits on
the roof
of southern africa and they've been
given a critical
task they must deliver covert 19
vaccines
to the nation
[Music]
but there is a terrible shortage here
and we have to fly
200 kilometers to pick up a couple of
dozen
jabs how many doses do you have
uh for now we are having 30 buses 30.
yes
how many doses are you going to need in
total then in total we
will need let me estimate
2 million doses two million dollars to
be at the secure sites yes okay
the fact is the vast majority in lesotho
are waiting for a vaccine tells you
something about how
how precious they are for sure yeah
definitely there might be a lot of these
being made but like having them here
you know the process to get them here
has just been so long and
detailed that it does make them precious
we flew on to a place called kubanyani
where key health workers
and vulnerable adults have not been
protected
and the pilot put us down on the
mountainside
our special cargo was handed over to a
nurse
but it won't go far in a district of 10
000
people how many people have been
vaccinated here so far
so far 73
73 people yes mostly the
village health workers and the health
center committee
and some of our colleagues here staff
members
okay yes you're gonna need a lot more
especially for the for the people here
yes
it is an isolated spot but the message
has gone
out about covert 19 as a third wave of
infection in africa
takes root and we watched as they began
to congregate
why do you want to get a covert vaccine
geek
[Laughter]
do you think the virus could come here
to the mountains
they were gathered in a room warmed up
by the sun
and given the first of a two-dose
vaccine
and the recipients said they were
grateful
[Music]
are you one of the lucky people the
fortunate people
the supply of vaccines in africa has
almost ground to a halt
with the world health organization
pleading with rich countries
to donate their stocks in some countries
they're
talking about vaccinating children now
here you're still vaccinating
health workers i wonder how do you feel
about that
hey we are not comfortable yes
it's not fair at all it's just to be
rolled out
as quick as possible because this
pandemic is killing people
the kingdom in the mountains has been
left behind in the race to vaccinate the
public
but as this shape-shifting virus
encircles the world
lesotho should be everybody's
responsibility
john sparks sky news in cuban yani